did it hit it you hit it wow 50K
is there five days left
perfect because I've secured a Saudi
sponsor we're gonna run this up to five
million yeah yeah yeah yeah welcome back
to the most racist podcast in the world
yeah
damn yeah you gotta run 50 miles dude
what flavor is this your Iron Man so
then that's when I'll do the Hot Chip is
after the 50 miles I'm a child so I saw
yellow and I thought lemon
yeah dude we're gonna add um [__] it
let's just you know World Series Pros
please
um if you've won a World Series of Poker
bracelet
please take some of your old winnings
and um just throw like a cool 250 000 on
this uh fundraiser yeah
yeah for your chance to win
a a
shout out
they have to for gamblers yeah oh right
incentivize them right well you're gonna
run 250 miles yeah yeah that'd be the
incentive yeah true due to Saudi Prince
donates a money like a sum of money and
he just says Cody this is the exact
amount of miles between my home and
Dubai
and your home in California in Los
Angeles California
um and I anticipate that you will run
all the way and then for the ocean don't
worry I've set up a charter boat there's
gonna be a treadmill on it and it will
it will move a mile exactly for everyone
you run on the treadmill
I would do that yeah that'd be insane
just running on a yacht dude I'm reading
a book right now about
um the king of Saudi Arabia oh Mohammed
bin Salman oh on his like rise to power
and but like what no
you said the king of Saudi Arabia yeah
hmm I thought that was Bush
George Bush no oh yeah I thought there's
a whole warrant like we won and yeah
yeah
anything that in Iraq
oh right American Education what can I
say no I'm kidding this must be
massively interesting it's called blood
and oil
but yeah that's him that looks like the
cover of his album
yeah that looks hard as hell MBS he
should start rapping he's so
just one of the things that's
interesting about this book is he's
telling you to read these books the this
was really interesting no but this is
the second book in a row you're like I'm
reading about this global conflict I'm
reading about this interesting thing on
the world stage what is promo what is
motivating you to read these books I
find it so interesting no I know but
where are you getting oh I just Kindle
recommends them to me
the fact that Kindle has an algo that
the kids yeah no that's cool like you go
to Amazon like on Kindle yeah you buy a
book and then it says like similar books
yeah you know what I do
I'd get this wreck on Kindle I'd be like
sick and I'd copy all 500 pages put in
chat GPT and be like give this to me in
three sentences
if you like write me another book just
like that yeah
now you know if you're sick you take it
to chat gbt and you're like
um
write a step-by-step instruction a
series of instructions for an AI video
program to make a documentary movie
about this for me yeah and you put that
in a machine
and then you wait seven days and you're
like oh yeah I just made a personal
documentary because I'm [__] stupid
yeah and it's gonna be yeah that's
pretty close to being able to do that
that's five months away yeah Netflix
it's over wave goodbye I did see some
tweets about AI video
and like how realistic it's getting yeah
let's talk about in a second but so
you're reading this book how deep are
you uh like halfway through what's your
reading pace
I'm pretty slow yeah yeah me too I'm
pretty like you know I can I can feel
like the brain rot yeah from social
media yeah and so it takes me a while to
get in that like Flow State where you
like actually are reading words yeah and
not just like reading words and thinking
about five other things at the same time
what's your what's your Optimal Reading
time
what do you mean like day of the time of
the day when do you take oh I don't know
probably morning see is this part of
your routine get up no cold plunge read
a book I'm pretty like sporadic when it
comes to reading it's like what if I'm
on a trip I'll do it okay like vacation
or which I'm always on yeah yeah we know
that
yeah we know you're always traveling no
I'm kidding but like you like no it's
really easy to read on a private jet
it's very relaxing no babies unless you
know you have your own but you just you
know pillow over their mouth on a plane
it's like the perfect thing yeah it is
and there's also Bloons td6 anyway so
you're reading this book there's also
one balloons td6 what's that oh yeah
yeah monkey game yeah monkey game paper
clip game remember that one oh yeah yeah
I forget
so I don't know the whole the whole
reason why I want to talk about this is
because like the just the like amount of
wealth
yeah you know these guys are sitting on
like oil fortunes oh yeah and um when he
was like 20
I think when he was like 22 or something
like that sort of like starting to like
uh collect Power
and make his way up to like challenge
the actual rifle heir to the throne
um he was like working really hard and
trying to make like a name for himself
and then he had a birthday party I think
in and I think they spent it was like a
month-long trip and I think he spent
like 20 million dollars or something
like that they went to the most
expensive resort with him and his like
five friends or something like that and
they had a hundred models from Russia
and Ukraine
flown in on all on Russia and Ukraine
wow yeah well back when they were cool
yeah I don't know if that was ever a
time
I don't know if that time ever happened
he hasn't read the book on that yet yeah
yeah yeah they had them all like STD
tested and then they're like we're gonna
fix this conflict right now yeah yeah
exactly Putin get in here yeah
um
and uh they like 100 100 people for like
five of him and his friends wow bizarre
uh but and they all just kind of just
play board games and yeah exactly yeah
I'm sure they did knitted sweaters and
stuff
um
and uh they flew Afrojack in I think
they had like four other DJs performed
this is like a party for him and his
like five friends and they spent 20
million dollars
absurd succession what it's just
succession yeah but like times five
thousand how much how much was he worth
1.4 trillion dollars or was that Saudi
aramco
I mean he owns he owns a ramco I'm
pretty sure so he owned he's the one who
owns Formula One yes and live golf yeah
like
so like he was basically the one
that along the along the way when he was
like
consolidating power he was like he made
it his goal to
um diversify Saudi Arabia's economy and
he set a goal so that like by 2024 it
was going to be like not only dependent
on oil so that's why he invested in
um the vision fund which was right you
know masayoshi-san or whatever is like
the biggest Venture fun of all time that
like you know put however many billions
into wework yeah and also like every
other Silicon Valley company a lot of
that money came from this guy do you
think if you had a billion dollars
tomorrow
you would you could maintain being a
normal person like mentally or do you
think you'd go nuts
um get a billion dollars I don't know I
feel like it would be hard you know what
they say right
the phrase
I believe biggie
that do you want you're familiar with
this or do you want me to no jog my
memory
um
in uh
uh money in addition to what was it
it's something it's coming
um money on top of no
Money Mo Problems that's what it is Mo
Money Mo pickleball team yeah yeah
that's my money mo pickleball teams see
that's what I'm saying I don't think I
could stop buying pickleball teams
I think that's actually what would
happen you get a billion dollars and you
dump it all in a pickleball and you'd be
like I swear it's gonna be a thing and
the world would go sorry man
we're sorry but you can't you stop
trying to make it happen and then Ben
comes out here and he buys the whole
your whole pickleball Endeavor yeah
Ben that's funny because that means like
of
like it's like it's like the name of the
father's name oh so you just you just
called him of
of
only
favored yeah there you go talal
talal pulls up and he buys your
pickleball Endeavor and he goes Cody
listen
um I don't know you know what he does he
invests in his own pickleball League
put so much funding behind it captures
all the market share collapses your lead
and then he shuts down his picklebally
and he says I really hated the fact that
you thought pickleball would be a thing
so I just wanted to just get it out of
there for sure it is whack yeah right
it's so stupid
yeah damn
I think if I had a billion dollars yeah
what about you
would you buy a yacht I just buy a
racetrack and then just be a absolute
weirdo
but even an absolute weirdo just buy
like a hundred cars I just drive them
naked and
allow people to watch me drive for free
and just but you have to be naked yeah
yeah no no yeah I'm the only one that's
naked yeah yeah I won't be naked I'll
wear a Speedo yeah okay yeah
and then like oh yeah I'll adopt some
weird mindset about like you know
clothes and our [__] and we should
connect with the Earth yeah yeah I'll
wear really small shorts only to like
humor people's participation in society
but I largely won't believe in it yeah
and then I'll just stand like too close
to people and like not brush my teeth
off yeah yeah okay yeah